é melhor não precisava ou trabalha com
desenvolvimento de software e isso você
pode imaginar
tive vários códigos etc eu fiz a
universidade de ciência da computação e
logo depois da universidade eu já entrei
num uma profissão que eu usei como se
fosse um estágio logo depois entrei aqui
na federal do abc como analista e é
interessante o esse caso porque eu
estava simplesmente passando de emprego
para o outro olhando para o salário
quando ele era maior então não estava
realmente escolhendo as coisas e hoje
hoje não já trabalha na empresa que
trabalha com empresas grandes nós mesmos
nós somos uma empresa grande a gente
está saindo após startup eo interessante
é porque essa foi uma empresa que
realmente escolhido entre outras outras
embora tinha conhecimento técnico que
mais me ajudou realmente escolher
altiseg adentro outra proposta recebeu
outras propostas foi o piano quando eu
estava na quando eu saí da altiseg foi
trabalhar em são paulo e nesse meio
tempo eu estava tipo muito numa fase
assim muito corrida estava correndo pra
fazer pra conseguir um trabalho melhor e
etc
era e eu estava fazendo tratamento
psicológico na época quando eu saía de
tratamento eu ia tirar o trabalho e lá
tinha um piano na estação de metrô que
aquele programa da prefeitura de piano
das citações
eu sempre leva aquele piano e falava
deixa pra lá vai mais um dia eu resolvi
realmente falar não deixa pra lá não vou
sentar e vou tocar um pouco e aí vem a
parte realmente interessante porque era
horário de pico aquele monte de gente
andando assim eu me aquele monte de
gente claro
de repente eu falei não opera deixou de
acelerar a sair sentem e comecei a tocar
e isso é uma experiência muito
interessante porque eu sou uma pessoa
introvertida com a maior parte do
pessoal que trabalha com o ipi
então é engraçado que coisa trabalhar
quando você entrou vertido você tem
aquela impressão de que todo mundo te
olhando assim tipo ah olha só ele vai
errar na hora em que ele raio vou chegar
e falar a você ro e no piano isso é
muito mais forte porque você está
tocando e você sabe exatamente o que
você errou porque você quem está mais
próximo do instrumento e aí eu estava
tocando e errava várias notas de tipo
pediu tempo e mesmo assim as pessoas
ouviam e paravam para ouvir duas ou três
vezes aconteceu de ter gente que tem
chegou até mim falou cara
você toca bem parabéns e eu falei nada
mas eu não toco bem e eu pensei poxa
vida mas se as pessoas olham pra mim me
vem tocando na estação e falando mas
você toca bem porque eu não posso tentar
fazer as coisas que eu sei que eu faço
bem por exemplo dá palestras sobre
assuntos que eu conheço e aí quando eu
comecei a fazer esse tipo de coisa da
palestra as pessoas começaram a falar
poxa é é é você sabe o que está falando
e eu comecei a treinar cartão e tal e as
pessoas começaram a me ligar em oferecer
entrevista e aí realmente pode escolher
o que eu queria hoje e é uma coisa que
acho interessante a causa seguinte
quando você tá no mundo moderno você tem
muita coisa que só se fala olha não
perca as oportunidades não perca as
oportunidades mas ninguém fala dizer não
e quando estava na faculdade com quando
elas ainda faculdade e precisava de um
estágio não tinha um estágio e aí uma
professora chegou pra mim foi o seguinte
olha a gente tem um mestrado prontinho
pra você eu falei mas espera
como assim o mestrado pronto pra mim não
tem emprego não sei o que eu quero ainda
e cantava na faculdade eu tinha vontade
de trabalhar com algumas coisas que hoje
trabalha exatamente com o posto por
exemplo pessoal falando em apresentação
que não tem que fugir de java eu gostava
muito de java causa da faculdade e hoje
em dia eu nunca trabalho
profissionalmente com java essa parte
interessante e quem conhece por exemplo
em outras línguas programação como o
clube sabe que o que o trabalho é
exatamente o oposto de java e eu
realmente achava que ele ia trabalhar
então eu rejeitei o mestrado isso me
lembrou uma história muito legal porque
outro dia tá começando com o chefe sobre
como eu fiz essa rejeita e ele me falou
que ele tem uma amiga que saiu da
universidade já entrou no mestrado e
depois entrou no doutorado com bolsa de
doutorado ela foi proposta doc no
exterior também tudo pago
deu à noite por um pouco tempo e hoje
ela é professora de tango
é estranho isso porque se falar poxa mas
ela teve todo esse tempo pra ela todo o
momento que ela estudou tudo que já foi
investido tudo que foi investido nela
ela dá aula de tango não tem nada contra
tango para ser bem sincero mas assim o
ponto é quanto tempo ela perdeu da vida
dele estudando para fazer uma coisa que
ela não vai atuar profissionalmente e é
isso que eu vim falar experiência quando
a gente hoje no brasil a gente tem uma
ênfase muito grande o diploma ao título
título diploma e tetra eu acho até que
teve um paralelo com sustentação que a
gente tem hoje de querer ostentar as
coisas mas enfim o e por exemplo no meu
caso me faltava experiência para saber o
que ia trabalhar no caso dessa
professora também faltava experiência
para saber quem ia trabalhar o que ela
ia querer fazer e este me lembro quando
eu entrei na aqui na loja bc
assim como na ufpb c assim como em
outros concursos também há o fbc ela tem
uma remuneração melhor para quem tem
nível universitário e uma remuneração
mais baixa para quem tem nível técnico e
eu fui incumbido da tarefa de criar o
seu desenvolvimento aqui e no primeiro
concurso
vieram pessoas que tinham conhecimento
técnico enviando pessoas tinham
conhecimento universitário mas no
mercado de ti e se ganha bem em geral
e esse salário do pessoal que era
universitário não estava de acordo não
sair do mercado depois ele chegou
aumentado tudo mais mas naquele até
naquele momento não estava adequada
e aí o que aconteceu é que o concurso de
técnico extremamente concorrido porque o
pessoal que entrar porque não tinha
diploma o concurso de analista não foi
tão concorrido assim então as pessoas
ganhavam mais pessoas ganhavam menos
e as pessoas ganhavam menos fazer um
serviço mais completo que as pessoas
leiam mais e hoje eu trabalho não é
assim a gente se preocupa menos com o
diploma mas com conhecimento pessoal da
pessoa e isso me lembra por exemplo
quando você não tem experiência tudo que
você sabe veio do ensino fundamental e
no ensino médio e hoje é tipo agitado eu
fiz por exemplo o ensino médio
profissionalizante em treinar
entrei no concurso para analista aqui de
técnico e analista em extremamente para
sempre menina lista em terceiro em
técnico então é uma coisa que estranha
mas enfim o eu lembro quando eu
today principalmente quando estudou no
colégio técnico não cansa na faculdade
no ensino fundamental
sempre tinha coisa como matemática e
matemática falava como é que eu vou usar
logaritmo e uma coisa que achei muito
legal é que uma vez eu vi um comediante
que era matemático que falou isso e fala
mais lugar onde você vá na prova do gari
time tá mas onde eu vou usar isso na
vida ele respondeu bom
a prova de um organismo faz parte da sua
vida
ok mas não é só isso que a gente quer
ter por exemplo se eu fosse dar uma aula
hoje por exemplo trigonometria último
falar simplesmente acho pontuar porque
porque tomando chá pontual poderiam
falar não imagina que você é
desenvolvedor do angry birds eye tem um
passarinho ali no ponto senhora ponta de
cima
se você pegar e pôr o dedo ali arrastar
o seu dedo até o ponto a você vai ver
que foi um triângulo aqui e se você
calcular o ângulo do ponto a você sabe
quanto o passeio tem que rodar para
apontar a posição certa e depois é
mandar embora
isso é uma coisa que eu acho que falta
para a gente ter realmente o aluno se
interessando no na matéria é você ter
essa vivência dele hoje é uma coisa
também já falei isso que o brasil
estimula muito o curso universitário mas
por exemplo principalmente nas áreas que
são mais amplas como por exemplo a área
de saúde a área de ti e que são áreas
que você pode entrar em várias várias
partes assim você não sabe muito bem
quando estava fazendo a faculdade o que
você vai querer ser
tem muita coisa que te atrái que te fala
nossa é muito legal mas segundo ele
falou mas eu quero que o que eu vou o
que não vão me encher o saco para
trabalhar porque gostava das coisas boas
de uma de uma profissão é muito fácil
agora você gosta das coisas ruins é
difícil eu por exemplo tem dias em que
eu faço três dias no mesmo pedaço de
três linhas de código
olhando pra quê faltava porque essa
porcaria não funciona
e eu gosto disso eu gosto muito disso e
hoje a gente tem coisas que podem nos
estimular a tomar essa decisão por
exemplo o youtube tem vídeo aulas
a wikipedia tem artigos que quando a
gente não sabe alguma coisa que pode
complementar
se falta conhecimento que você veio do
ensino fundamental você tem o
o cadê minha são todas as coisas
infelizmente são inglês sabe que perde
em português tipo é muito confiável a
equipe inglesa costuma ter coisas
melhores
e aí hoje por exemplo quando é preciso
fazer muita coisa de de cálculo porque
estava trabalhando outros recorrente
neurais e ainda não sou bem assim de
matemática
eu uso o wolphram alpha que é um posso
falar a calcular pra mim é derivada de
não sei o que ele me traz o resultado
numa boa
não estou dizendo pra gente usar isso
sempre nas escolas praticam em cena
derivada pessoa simplesmente que se
falta algum conhecimento que a gente
deveria ter na universidade a gente
poderia usar estimular mais as
tecnologias que ensina o aluno sozinho
sem precisar por exemplo mobilizar mais
pessoas
fala pra ele olha entra nesse site
qik.com academy que você vai ter
conhecimentos legais e aí entra um ponto
interessante da wikipedia a wikipédia
direta tendo revisões se ela é confiável
ou não
ela inclusive tem uma tv um artigo na
revista mente uma revista no artigo na
revista alemã titanick mostrou que ela é
confiável tem uma confiabilidade boa
como outras enciclopédias
porém os artigos da wikipédia não
escritos por especialistas isso é uma
coisa ruim porque puxa pode ter um
assunto muito importante que não tá lá
mas também uma coisa boa porque quem já
leu o livro de matemática queria
descobrir um conceito sabe como é que é
ele que passa um símbolo por exemplo de
pertence
na página seguinte já tem competência
para 150 lugares pra você perguntar
entender os conceitos que dependem
daquilo ao estacionamento tem uma
linguagem mais fácil pra gente e aí eu
sugiro euros pelo menos fiz isso eu saí
do curso técnico cheguei no trabalho é
um pouco e falei não é isso mesmo que eu
quero eu queria complementar meus
estudos na universidade
e aí vem um ponto também que eu senti
muita dificuldade
hoje em dia aquela idéia do mestre que
ela é automaticamente obedecido e
automaticamente já sabe tudo mas ela não
existe mais
eu tive um estudo muito eu tive um
problema muito grande na minha faculdade
que eu tive um professor que me ensinou
coisas erradas quando estava vendo
quanto na faculdade
em compensação por exemplo descobrir
dois anos depois que essas coisas
erradas e minha esposa
ela hoje está fazendo faculdade na área
de saúde e ela descobriu no mesmo dia
que o professor tinha alguma coisa
errada
o professor tinha falado que tinha uma
tribo africana canibal que faziam enfim
ela falou não pára aí
a primeira coisa a aplicação de 54
países
qual desses países têm a tribo ea
segunda coisa que logo no mesmo dia ela
falou o tribunal nem da áfrica é de um
outro lugar enfim o problema é que a
gente precisa aprender a falar não sei
todos nós assim não só professores mas
todos nós devemos a ela não sei não sei
o que vou fazer não sei como é que é
isso e principalmente na faculdade
chegou o momento de falar porque uma
pequena breno isso é muito comum por
exemplo uma área de teve um professor dá
aula de física seu físico
se a gente pudesse ter um físico
professor vezes conversando com alguém
digita e mesmo com algumas prioridades
de ir falando olha que eu vou me diz
aqui ou pensou em dar a esse assunto
para o aluno para onde ele vai usar isso
ou pelo menos dá acesso o aluno pessoal
hoje em dia eu vejo eu vejo muito
universidade tem brigas internas entre
as faculdades
isso prejudica muito o aluno porque se
você depende de uma coisa de uma outra
faculdade
e essa faculdade brigada com a sua a
minha mala teve um fez um curso na
universidade de florianópolis na federal
de florianópolis
ela tinha problemas e não consegui
equipamento porque a faculdade dela era
obrigado a faculdade dos outros caras
que tinham o equipamento então é uma
coisa muito muito da nossa abrangente e
aí pra encerrar com esses dois slides eu
vou falar do poder da experiência a
experiência teve nossa várias portas
você fala bem mas eu quero ir nessa
porque eu já estudei já pratiquei isso e
eu sei que eu quero isso
o poder da experiência te dá a
possibilidade de o citi po se
profissionalizar e depois estudar mais
naquilo por exemplo uma estrada que é
uma coisa eu tentei fazer há pouco tempo
agora que o mercado poderia fazer com a
gente principalmente nós que estamos
trabalhando agora é abrir as portas para
quem trabalha porque o mestrado que eu
fiz e não falava isso mas eu quando eu
comecei a fazer melhor descobri que
precisava de dedicação exclusiva
porque as aulas eram as duas horas da
tarde às três horas da tarde
ele era na usp leste então pra ir até lá
eu demorava uma hora então eu perdi
praticamente metade do meu dia de
trabalho indo e voltando da usp leste só
para fazer mestrado e aí vem aquela
idéia
estude bastante mas não se mata de
estudar porque o ponto que eu vejo muita
gente se mata de estudar e de repente
falar poxa mas que está estudando porque
eu tô olhando isso eu vi uma vez uma
frase muito legal que as pessoas
costumam andar demais mas elas para um
pouco tempo a olhar para as pegadas e é
isso é uma coisa que eu sugiro assim a
gente tem que põe talvez desacelerar um
pouco presente quando a gente está na
neura de que estudar de querer fazer as
coisas de quem já engajar um deixar o
mestrado e doutorado alguma coisa
ascende para um pouco ela não deixa eu
ver será que é isso mesmo que eu gosto
mas é o poder de você
mais pra frente falar por não gostei
disso
e se a gente do demais a gente está num
mestrado doutorado e fala pouco mas eu
não gosto disso
o crime aconteceu no caso da professora
do meu amigo que aconteceu com uma amiga
pessoal minha ela fez profissionalização
uma doença específica que ela está
fazendo medicina e aí quando estava
fazendo essa profissionalização ela
largou tudo e foi fazer e isso porque
ela falou eu não gosto disso
quanto mais cedo a gente puder falar não
gosto disso vou desistir desse curso e
fazer outra coisa melhor na minha
faculdade especificamente entraram 80
pessoas se formaram 15 e cinco atuam na
área então é algo que a gente tem que
pensar um pouco e por fim queria contar
um outro caso aqui esse é um caso e
também preocupante para mim um amigo meu
trabalhou comigo onde eu estou
trabalhando hoje ele era do exército e
ele fez o curso do exército de treinar
novas novas pessoas
claro não vou querer fazer uma
comparação tão assim pesada mas enfim a
idéia é que ele me falou isso no
exército você tira a dignidade da pessoa
depois você tira a o conforto dela e
depois de deixar ocupar o tempo todo
porque ela não pensa que obedece
agora quando eu fiz mestrado
aconteceu uma coisa muito triste comigo
que quando cheguei pra fazer o piso do
paço com paetês entra e entreguei os
documentos em várias universidades e uma
das universidades que entreguei eu
entrei para a professora e na verdade eu
entrei pra uma pessoa perguntei
professor onde fica a secretaria porque
eu estava lá
prezado enfim ela começou a me ofender
aí eu falei mas peraí é mas se você está
querendo fazer mestrado em saúde
secretaria e não sei o que eu falei em
uma pedra
só quero saber da secretaria tipo não
conseguiu mas ela tentou tirar minha
dignidade nessa hora
george tinha outros casos ela quando
conseguiu finalmente entrar na no
mestrado
eu passei muitas horas estudando muitas
horas não tinha muito conceito que não
sabia que não tinha visto e que enfim
não foi pego isso no processo seletivo
da universidade da usp leste no caso
passei muito muito muito tempo estudando
então acabou contando já com folha que
não tinha mais de conforto só tinha
horas de estudo
então o final de semana feriados e as
coisas sim todos horas de conforto das
horas de estudo e aí de repente quando
eu realmente falei 'não beleza é eu vou
conseguir traindo certo vou entregar os
exercícios
o sistema deles tipo rompeu parte do
projeto trabalha melhor
isso normalmente acontecia não foi
avisado então enfim e um sistema e por
fim várias coisas que eu entreguei
precisavam de relatórios juntos e eu
também não fui avisado meio que é como
se eu tivesse que saber isso
automaticamente e outras várias
informações que precisava fazer tantas
disciplinas ao mesmo tempo está fazendo
- enfim tinha muita informação que não
tinha pra mim então eu fiquei muito
preocupado fiquei muito tempo tipo muito
estressado mesmo até o momento eu falei
não dá certo eu saí da onu do mestrado e
aí eu fiquei pensando assim puxa vida a
academia ela tem que te estimula a
pensar
ela estimula a tomar novas idéias a
pensar e etc se não obedecer cegamente
as pessoas mas acho que é exatamente o
contrário e eu me senti meio igual assim
como se estivesse num treinamento
militar assim extremamente rígido com
regras do tipo não pensa é isso
obrigado gente